on the action the government is taking
to improve patient Choice as a way to
help reduce NHS waiting times one of the
government's five key priorities
there are currently significant
variations in waiting times across the
country and sometimes even within the
same integrated care system
analysis from the patients Association
suggests that improved patient Choice
can reduce waiting times by up to three
months so when he took office last year
the Prime Minister promised to make it
easier for patients to make a meaningful
choice and to raise public awareness of
the patient's right to choose
but in terms of the speaker because of
the pandemic we have an NHS waiting list
at over 7.3 million I love that number
around 80 percent are waiting for
outpatient appointments with around 20
waiting for operations greater patient
choice will help us address this built
up demand including where appropriate
opening more routes for NHS patients to
get treatment free at the point of
access in the independent sector
providing it meets NHS costs and
standards because we should use all
available capacity in tackling the
pandemic backlogs for example for
patients currently waiting for ear nose
and throat treatment in London the
weight could be up to four months
shorter with another provider or trauma
and Orthopedics in the Northwest
choosing another provider in the same
region could cut your weight by three
months so empowering patients to
exercise their right to choose was one
of the key recommendations of the
elective recovery task force who
identified it as a vital way of
delivering the post-pandemic recovery
when addressing the 78 week backlog
analysis at the time showed that half of
those who were waiting over 78 weeks for
elective care were in just 11 trusts
which reinforced the opportunity offered
by raising awareness of patient choice
and making it easier for patients to
exercise that in a meaningful way
as well as cutting waiting lists Choice
empowers patients in terms of which
aspects of the hospital service matters
most to them
patients themselves can prioritize speed
of care alongside other factors such as
distance traveled the CQC rating of the
provider or they may have had previous
care from a consultant-led team and want
to return to that team
We Believe empowering the patient is
intrinsically a good thing and we
believe it cannot just be The Preserve
of those groups with the sharpest elbows
it must be open to all indeed research
from the Kings fund has found and I
quote odor respondents those with no
qualifications and those from a mixed
and non-white background were more
likely to Value choice
next when we combine improved patient
Choice with better real-time data and
greater transparency we can drive up
standards where patients know much more
about how their local hospital is
performing the pressure is on poor
performers to close the gap with their
near neighbors where patients are often
being treated more quickly
modern Deputy speaker the pay the case
for patient choice is clear
so to improve this we are announcing
significant changes in a number of areas
the first is technology over 30 million
people have now signed up for the NHS
app and our Target is for three quarters
of all adults in England to be
registered by next march the app is
already giving patients an improved
front door for NHS service and we're
continuing to build on that
when GPS make a referral they will make
a short list of the five most suitable
providers and patients will be able to
choose from the shortlist on the NHS app
to support this in March we completed
the worker providing a single list of
providers for those shortlists
irrespective of whether those services
are commissioned locally or nationally
while The Honorable members plan
opposite to organize waiting lists on a
regional basis might sound like a good
idea on paper in reality it would add an
extra layer of bureaucracy because
nationalists under this conservative
government will Empower patients to pick
wherever they choose for example a
patient registered in Sheffield might
happily choose to receive treatment in
Manchester particularly if they have
family members in Manchester that can
help with their care and Recovery
Madame Deputy speaker the second area of
work is to improve the experience for
those already on waiter lists so they
can get treatment more quickly
from October 2023 patients have waited
more than 40 weeks for an appointment or
who have a decision to treat but do not
have a treatment date will be able to
request a transfer to another provider
with a shorter waiting list
it is then our ambition to expand this
offer to other groups and long waiters
and we will work to offer this to more
groups regressively lowering this
towards 18 weeks as fast as is
clinically possible
our third focus is around Communications
we want to increase the Public's
awareness of today's announcement with a
national campaign with a particular aim
to reach those groups who are most
likely to benefit from greater Choice as
well as those least likely to exercise
it we will also make sure GP practices
and others who refer patients for
consultant-led care are offering more
patient choice and that they are
supported with the right training and
Tech
fourth Madame Deputy speaker we will
focus on transparency
with real-time information on
performance it will be made more
transparent for patients so they get a
clearer understanding of the variations
from place to place helping them to
exercise informed choice we have worked
to make ratings by the Care Quality
commission available and accessible to
all and we are merging the my planned
care platform into the NHS website
Madame W speaker the party opposite has
been busy announcing initiatives we
already have underway
like expanding the nhsr
embracing virtual Awards stopping kids
from vaping but well they've been busy
talking in England and failing to act on
behalf of patients in Wales we've been
busy acting to empower patients and our
announcement today is another example of
that
Madame Deputy speaker we are committed
to cutting NHS waiting lists today's
announcement will help us do that by
empowering patients to access quicker
treatment in hospitals with available
capacity by giving patients the
technology so they can exercise their
right to choose by giving patients the
information to help them make that
choice and by increasing Communications
to raise public awareness of their right
to choose and by fostering much greater
transparency and through funding that
follows the patient to encourage trust
to improve their offer to patients to
better match the service offered in
hospitals elsewhere
taken together this will enable patients
to access treatment more quickly and
meet this government's priority of
reducing NHS waiting lists I commend
this statement to the house
Shadow secretary of state was streeting
thank you madam Deputy speaker and can I
thank the Secretary of State for
advanced site of this statement and also
join him in both paying tribute to the
late Karen Lumley and even more
importantly extending condolences to her
family and many friends right across the
house but particularly on the opposite
benches for her loss which I know that
the sadness has felt very deeply across
the whole house
and turning to this first of the two
statements Madame Deputy speaker it's
he's the quantity of today's statements
are not matched by quality in the week
where the leader of the opposition
announced Labor's plans to give patients
more Choice with regional waiting lists
for care and more power through the NHS
app the conservatives big idea to cut
waiting times is to give patients a
choice they already have in fact it's
thanks to the last Labor government that
patients waiting for plan treatment
already have a right to choose an
alternative provider if they've been
waiting too long and in fact beneath the
spin his announcement today is actually
a watering down of the measures that are
already in place he says patients will
get the right to choose an alternative
provider if they have been waiting
longer than 40 weeks but in 2019 the
conservatives said patients should have
this right after 26 weeks which even
then was worse than the 18-week standard
that patients were already entitled to
thanks to the law labor government isn't
it the case that the health secretary is
once again Shifting the goal posts
because he can't even meet his own
standards let alone those that patients
expect he concluded his statement Madame
Deputy speaker by talking about his
government's record a bold move because
7.3 million people are currently waiting
for Planned treatment in England that's
the highest number on record and as
usual he says this is because of the
pandemic but it was already at a record
high before the pandemic and behind this
shocking statistic are real people
waiting waiting waiting in agony and it
doesn't matter how much he says the
government is committed to reducing the
waiting list people can see with their
own eyes the numbers that do not lie
which is that waiting lists are getting
higher things are getting worse not
better and his total incompetence in
preventing strike action in the NHS it
has inflicted Untold misery on patience
so far the total number of appointments
affected by NHS strikes in recent months
is more than half a million a figure the
health secretary called deeply
disappointing well Madame Deputy speaker
that's something that he and I can agree
on for once but with another round of
strike action planned by Junior doctors
he must surely see the risk to Patient
choice and waiting list so what is his
plan ministers blame strikes as if
they're mere bystanders but it was their
refusal to speak to nurses paramedics
and Junior doctors that force them out
on strike in the first place so I'm
afraid his warm words today just aren't
going to cut it when all when all he is
doing is giving more patience more
Choice over where their next deployment
is going to or operation is going to be
canceled because of the strikes that he
and the Prime Minister have failed to
prevent and finally Madame Deputy
speaker let me turn to the supermassive
black hole at the heart of today's
announcement and I will keep on
reminding him of this until the the
penny drops it doesn't matter which
hospital you choose patients can only
get Care on time if there are enough
staff to treat them so why are we still
waiting for the NHS Workforce plan that
the system is crying out for why do we
have net migration at the highest level
ever with the government over relying on
recruiting staff from overseas because
they can't be bothered to train
homegrown Talent where is the plan to
train the doctors and nurses the NHS is
desperately short of Labor has set out
our plan to double Medical School places
training seven and a half thousand more
doctors and ten thousand more nurses and
midwives a year paid for by abolishing
the non-dom tax status I offer a note
they they
they I'm afraid they like non-doms more
than nurses Madam Deputy speaker and the
public are not with them on that so let
me let me in the spirit of generosity
before we break for the recess once
again making a generous offer our fully
costed fully funded plan it is available
to him and it's available to them and
and they shouldn't laugh too much now
because I would wager on the fact that
before we break for the summer they will
finally swallow their pride and announce
the doubling of medical school places we
will wait and see but Madam Deputy
speaker after 13 years of conservative
government people can now see for
themselves where it has landed this
country and they can compare it to 13
years of Labor government which
delivered the shortest waiting times and
the highest patient satisfaction in
history we will offer real choice and
cut waiting time so the NHS is there
when you need it we did it before we did
it again we have the ideas we have the
plan that's why only labor can build an
NHS it's fit for the future
not since the famous One Pian income tax
from the midday which used to be spent
on every issue that it was going past
like a passing bus have we had the
non-dumb money and it's no spent in so
many different ways and it's no wonder
that he he said it with a smile I think
the house could see uh how credible that
uh proposal uh is but the theme of his
response Madame Deputy speaker was
comparison and I think we should start
with the substance of the announcement
patient choice and compare that with
where labor or enough is in Wales
because in Wales you do not have the
ability to choose where you receive
treatment that right is not offered to
patients NHS Wells her patients
registered with the GP and Wales do not
have a statutory right to choose at
which hospital they receive treatment so
we can compare a government in England
that is empowering patients allowing
them to exercise their choice giving
them the information the technology to
do so with NHS Wales run by the labor
party which deprives them of their
choice although I slightly hesitate
Madam speaker as to whether I'm supposed
to
with Wales because the member for Denton
and Redditch on the the healthfront
bench said he does not want labor to be
judged on their record in Wales now of
course that's slightly confusing Madame
Deputy speaker because the leader of the
labor party no less says that he wants
and I quote a blueprint labored in Wales
to be and I quote a blueprint for what
labor can do across the UK so they can't
even compare moments themselves never
mind compare between England and Wales
he then turned uh to strike action Madam
Deputy speaker where he seemed to skirt
over the fact that the government has
reached a deal with the NHS staff
Council in terms of the agenda for
change staff and it was one that his own
Union it's one that his own Union Unison
voted 74 in favor of so so his own Union
the union that gives him money was was a
union that supported the deal that we
reached with them he chunters Madam
doesn't speak about Junior doctors those
that others that were in the chamber
with him last time heard him say he
didn't support the demands of the junior
doctors at 35 so so he he doesn't
support their demands and in fact
actually when we did negotiate with them
they even increased it to 49 if they
added in uh next year as well so the
position there is further confused and
the reality is in Wales Madame Deputy
speaker it will come as no surprise to
the house to discover that you're almost
twice as likely to be waiting for
treatment as you are in England and that
is the true comparison that we are
addressing and you can see that uh
played through in those that are waiting
more than 18 weeks in England we
virtually eliminated 78-week weights at
the end of March it was under 11 000 but
in Wales it will come as no surprise to
members that it was much closer to 75
000 and of course that is on a smaller
population in Wales with a witch so we
can compare we can compare on waiting
times which we in England are bringing
down we haven't left his plan we cleared
virtually all the two-year weights in
the summer we uh played over 90 percent
of the 18-month weights at the end of
March and that contrasts with Wales we
are giving patients the choice we're
enabling them to to move if they want to
to get quicker treatment as where we're
on the side of patients we can see what
the labor party are doing by their
disastrous performance in Wales
[Applause]
chairman of the select committee Steve
Bryan thank you this former patient
Choice has been available of course for
at least 15 years it just hasn't been
made available to to patients so can the
Secretary of State confirm that the
referral management centers sitting at
ICB level will be compelled not asked to
either change that or get out of the way
altogether and given the vast majority
of those on the waiting list are already
there with a specific trust how exactly
will they've given the option to stick
where they are or twist and receive
tweak treatment and exercising that
renewed Choice sooner
so he makes as of a a very shrewd point
and yes the referral centers are all
part of this the key Focus the initial
focus is on the initials of the GP
referral and how we Empower that with
better data transparency have the tech
than to facilitate that the referral
centers are part of this but we also
then want to roll it out from October to
the 40 year out before two week weeks
and then bring those weights uh down uh
to to the 18 weeks so it has that wider
scope there's a clear plan and that's
what we set out for the house today
Bell reverse speaker and Karen Lumley
was indeed a wonderful woman of thoughts
and prayers are with her family at this
difficult time this is an admirable
statement really but the how do patients
have the choice Secretary of State if he
has not addressed the workforce issue so
my question is when will he address the
workforce issue when will he speak to
the junior doctors
as I touched on on my statement the
choice is there now first it's illegal
right now but secondly patients only
around 10 percent of exercise in it
there is massive variation in the system
now with the existing uh worthless we
are increasing the workforce and we've
made a commitment to come forward with
the workforce plan but the point is
there is variation within the system now
what patient choice is about is an
empowering patients to take advantage of
that and to access treatment earlier for
example if they're willing to travel
often small distances to access it
Deputy speaker I really do welcome the
revolution in patient choice that my
writable friend has outlined but as
chairman of the all party parliamentary
group on minimally invasive cancer
therapies it's clear that some of those
cutting-edge Technologies and treatments
are only available in certain trusts
under certain Consultants so can my
right to my friend confirm that within
the choice available to patients they
will be able to choose centers that have
unique treatments rather than just
Universal treatments that are available
everywhere
yes I I can and a part of this is
allowing patients to choose on a number
of factors so some may as I touched on
in my uh opening remarks uh have had
past treatments and want to go back to a
particular consultant-led team some may
want to look at CQC ratings and other
performance metrics some may uh want the
convenience of not traveling uh
relatively small numbers say they're not
prepared to travel far more or willing
to prepared uh to travel so patients
will make a a we'll look at a range of
factors in shaping their uh decision but
the key is to have transparency on that
and then the technology to better enable
patients to create control
Daisy cook
book
we all want to see real patient choice
but for millions of people who are
waiting in pain a choice between
traveling miles away or paying to go
private is really no choice at all we
all know that the key to unlocking the
millions of people on the NHS backlog is
bringing is tackling the crisis in the
workforce so why on Earth are we
spending precious parliamentary time
talking about the NHS App instead of the
NHS Workforce yeah we aren't talking in
this statement about the wider Workforce
she mentioned the private capacity uh
this patient choice will enable people
to make much better use of the
independent sector where they're able to
do so free at the point of access it's
about saying given the size of the
challenge we have with the pandemic uh
backwards how do we make use of the full
capacity that we have both across the
NHS but including in the independent
sector
Dr Kieran Mullen
yeah I think the issue with variation in
waiting times is actually a symbolic of
variation of All Sorts across NHS and my
previous employer the national clinical
audit program commissioner focus on
identifying and spreading it can the
minister join me in meeting their CEO
Jane Ingram to hear her insights on
tackling this Challenge and join me also
in paying tribute to her as she retires
after 10 years of a dedicated public
servant in this role
well I'm very happy to join him in
paying tribute to Jane Ingram uh who as
he says he's retiring after to 10 years
she has a long history of working to
improve the quality of healthcare within
the NHS it's right that he pays tribute
to her and I'm sure the ministerial team
will be Keen to engage with him on any
lessons from my career
thank you madam Deputy speaker the
Secretary of State's words will ring
Hollow
um around patient Choice until he
actually addresses the NHS Workforce
crisis in Ophthalmology 80 of eye units
do not have enough Consultants to meet
the current demand and we know that last
year 65 of those units had to rely on
locomes now labor has a fully funded
plan for the biggest Workforce expansion
in NHS history where
is his plan because he hasn't answered
previous questions and can he say
whether this plan this Workforce plan
will actually address the deficit in Eye
Health Ophthalmology
well as the record shows numbers have
been increasing there's 47 000 more
doctors than uh 2010 over 52 000 more
nurses within primary care we have
already reached our Manifesto commitment
in terms of additional roles that we
brought into Primary Care to deliver
more appointments we've said repeatedly
we'll bring forward a Workforce plan and
we're committed to doing so shortly
sir Edward Lee congratulations on
promote promoting more Choice than in
the Socialist Republic of Wales a pretty
low bar but can we go further and
promote real Choice by adopting two
previous policies of the conservative
party both would be wildly popular one
is the patient's passport by which you
can get a free operation of the NHS or
you can take the same cost to a private
or charitable Hospital which will
promote choice and accountability and
secondly uh tax relief for Private
health insurance a matter of the
chancellor but the Secretary of State
could have a quiet word with his right
honorable friend
has lobbied me a number of times on this
issue including outside the chamber he
as such a senior Parliament over and
well knows that uh issues are tactile
matter for the chancellor and certainly
is a former treasury Minister that's not
an area but I'm sure the chancellor will
have noted his wider point
very much for his very positive state in
common today the host today and
referring to point to the long waiters
that he refers to
um one of those off neglected areas of
access are those with the inpatient
specialized eating disorders in in
Northern Ireland that means that they
don't have an accessible Clinic that
they long allows my constituents uh the
choice between a week a weekly weigh-in
with a GP and specialized treatment what
discussion and practical and physical
assistance can the Secretary of State
give to the health department at the
northern company to help those with
eating disorders thanks for watching
will as so often anyways is an extremely
important point in terms of how we
tackle uh those serious issues in terms
of Eating Disorders we are as he knows
increasing our funding into mental
health it was a key priority within the
long-term plan NX 2.3 billion a year of
funding uh in terms of different
approaches we're looking much more
actively at our use of digital apps and
platforms and that was an area that the
the chancellor specifically funded at
the last budget but also looking at how
we address mental health issues earlier
particularly with children and rolling
out our program in schools with mental
health support teams because obviously
early intervention has significant
benefits and targeting schools is a
great way to do that
kit malthouse
Deputy speaker I too congratulate the
Secretary of State for a profoundly
conservative step forward in dealing
with the with the waiting list issue
we agree with me that the provision of
Greater patient Choice holds out the
possibility of stimulating more
investment in private sector capacity
particularly for volume
procedures hips knees those kind of
things however the private sector to
make those heavy investments in
facilities requires some long-range
certainty so as waiting lists uh fall
will he be reviewing the threshold time
limit which patients can seek private
sector assistance in getting their
operation done more swiftly so that the
efficiencies of the private sector can
be realized for the system as a whole in
the longer term very good well he raises
a very good point obviously as he well
knows interaction between what is on and
off balance sheets uh the sort of area
where I think his point particularly
relates is looking at the role of
diagnostic Centers so for example I was
looking at the facility in Blackpool
that was using artificial intelligence
in its endoscopy which was picking up 20
more cases than we'll be seeing with the
human eye so thinking about how we use
the private sector to add more capacity
at scale and Pace how it can use the
latest technology we need to do that in
a way that is obviously compliant with
treasury rules but I think ensuring that
there is greater capacity in the system
but doing so where it is free at the
point of access to NHS patients is an
area where obviously we we have already
done quite a lot but there's always
scope to look at a fresh
which undoubtedly will help cut waiting
lists in my constituency of Keithley and
Oakley but can my right honorable friend
confirm that this expansion will be
available to those on the waiting lists
longest first
well I can confirm that from October we
will weld this out to those who are
waiting more than 40 weeks to prioritize
exactly as he touched on in his remarks
and then we will look to bring that down
over time but focusing first on those
longest weights
and finally Louis French thank you madam
Deputy speaker and I completely share my
honorable friend's desire to increase
patient choice and reduce waiting times
one way we can do that in southeast
London is the further expand the number
of services at Queen Mary's Hospital
sidcup which is an excellent model
modern hospital with the capacity to
expand Services however there needs to
be a will within the NHS leadership
especially the new integrated care
boards to get on and do so particularly
with regards to community Diagnostics
well my right honorable friend please
agree to meet with me to discuss further
how we can improve patient choice and
patient outcomes in Bexley
I share his desire firstly one of the
things we do as part of this
announcement is through payment
following the patient incentivized trust
to take on more which further underpins
uh patient Choice uh his other point in
terms of the acceleration of the
Diagnostic Center uh that is something
that we're very actively engaged on as a
result of ministerial intervention we
have speeded up the Diagnostic Center
program and I look forward to updating
the house on just how many additional
scans and tests will now be done this
year as opposed to the original plans
for those tests to have been done in
2024 and are very happy to have further
discussions with him
thank you that concludes the proceedings
on the first statement and so we proceed
to the second statement of the day from
the Secretary of State for health
I'm just
allowing Well normally I allow a bit of
movement between between statements but
um it seems that the change you've seen
in Personnel is not necessary that
everybody is already in place so
Secretary of State Steve Bartley okay
it's like a two-for-one statement offer
uh today it's a thank you madam Deputy
speaker with permission I'd like to make
a statement on the new hospital program
as we celebrate 75 years of the NHS this
summer we must continue to set up its
success for 75 years to come the heart
of this is our new hospital program the
biggest Hospital building program in a
generation which will help us to deliver
on our Manifesto commitment to build 40
new hospitals by 2030. and today I can
reconfirm to the house our commitment
for 40 new hospitals to be built by
2013.
[Music]
Madame Deputy speaker we made our
Manifesto commitment in 2019 and in 2020
we listed 40 schemes as part of the new
hospital program
since we formally launched those schemes
we have learned more about the use of
reinforced autoclaved area concrete
which is more commonly known as rack and
rack is a lightweight form of concrete
which between the mid-1950s and the
mid-1980s was commonly used in
construction on a number of public
buildings including hospitals often on
booze and occasionally in walls and
Floors
we now know that rack has a limited
lifespan with difficult and dangerous
consequences for the people who rely on
or work in those hospitals
I know this has caused considerable
concern to colleagues in this house to
NHS staff in those hospitals
and to constituents who are treated in
them
Madam Deputy speaker we remain committed
to eradicating rack from The Wider NHS
estate
as part of the spending review
allocation up to 2024 5 we allocated the
affected trust 685 million pounds in
immediate support
but in some cases we must go much
further
seven hospitals in England have been
constructed either wholly or a major
part with rack
and an independent assessment shows they
are not safe to operate Beyond 2030.
two of the hospitals are already part of
the new hospitals program namely the
West Suffolk hospital and the James
Paget Hospital
the five remaining hospitals has
submitted expressions of interest to
join the program
but are not yet part of it and these are
Airedale General and Keithley Queen
Elizabeth Hospital in King's Lynn hinch
and Brook near Huntington
and Finley Park in Surrey
Madame Deputy speaker we accept in full
the independent assessment that these
hospitals are not safe to operate Beyond
2030. and today I can confirm to the
house that we will expand our new
hospitals program to include those five
hospitals built with significant demands
taken together with the two right
hospitals already in the program the
seven rack hospitals will be completely
rebuilt using a standardized design
known as Hospital 2.0
with the aim of completing all Southern
by 2030. and I can confirm to the house
today that these new hospitals will be
fully funded
all those
pains so tirelessly for new hospitals to
be built to replace the existing rack
hospitals including amongst others the
member for Keithley and the member for
Shipley who have championed eldel
specifically
the right honorable member for sorry
Heath who campaigns so strongly for
frimley The Honorable member for
Huntington who lobbied hard for hitching
book The Honorable members for edisbury
crew and lampwich who led the campaign
on Layton and the honorable members for
Northwest Norfolk my PPS The Honorable
member for North Norfolk and the right
honorable member for Southwest Norfolk
who all campaign so assiduously in terms
of King's Lynn
taken together
the new hospital program represents a
huge commitment to strengthen the NHS
estate
since 2020 we have committed to invest
3.7 billion pounds by under Financial
year 2425 and we expect the total
investment to now be over 20 billion
pounds for the program as a whole
resolving the uncertainty over the rack
hospitals which today's announcement
achieves in turn allows much needed
Clarity for the rest of the new hospital
program
the program has already been divided
into cohorts one to four with
construction in cohort one already
started
so turning first to cohort while Madam
Deputy speaker there are eight schemes
two hospitals already open to patients
with the new Louisa Martindale building
at the Royal Sussex County Hospital in
Brighton due to open later this year and
work at more Fields Eye Hospital due to
start imminently having cleared its
final business case
turning next to cohort 2 Madame Deputy
speaker which comprises 10 schemes the
following schemes will now be ready to
proceed in line with the plan set out by
their respective trusts the National
Rehabilitation Center dotford emergency
care hospital in Plymouth the Cambridge
cancer research hospital the Dorset
County Hospital in Dorchester the Saint
Anne's Hospital the Christchurch
Hospital the Royal Bournemouth hospital
and the pool Hospital which are all in
Dorset
a further two schemes within cohort 2
namely shotley Bridge Community Hospital
and the women and children's hospital in
Cornwall will also be approved to
proceed but in line with the
standardized Design Elements we are
promoting through Hospital 2.0 on which
I will set out further details in a
moment
as such Madame Deputy speaker with the
uncertainty surrounding the rap
Hospitals now addressed all the cohort 2
schemes can proceed and they will be
fully funded
turning to the cohort 3 schemes which
include major Hospital New builds in
Sutton whips cross Hillingdon Watford
Harlow Leeds and Leicester
today's announcement confirms these
schemes will now proceed and be fully
funded
they will be constructed using the
hospital two-point survival standardized
approach
and it is worth reminding The House of
the merits of using that methodology
first while longer is taken over the
initial design
rather than each scheme beginning to
construct its own bespoke design
the current approach has meant the
average time from design to completion
of a major hospital has been around 11
and a half years
by embracing modern methods of
construction we will massively speed up
the construction phase and in addition
accelerate Treasury and other
governments government Assurance
processes
so while there has been much debate to
date on when hospitals start
the more important issue is when schemes
are completed and a standardized modular
design has been shown to work in other
sectors for example when building
schools prisons and indeed is widespread
across the private sector
today's announcement confirms that all
cohort tree schemes can now proceed and
in turn enabling Works which had been
held up due to the uncertainty on the
rack hospitals can now progress
and I want to pay tribute to the right
honorable and honorable members who have
campaigned so strongly for the cohort
III hospitals to proceed including right
honorable member for Oxbridge and South
ruislip the right honorable member for
chingford and Woodford green the right
honorable member for Harley the right
honorable ebbing forest and the right
honorable member for Hartford and
stortford all of whom I know can't raise
points in this statement Madame Deputy
is the speaker but I know all three have
championed Harlow and its case
and the member for Carl Shelton and
Wallington to name just some of those
who have raised these issues
they have asked for the update they have
called for the program and then don't
want to hear it when the announcement is
being made
certainly no uh Madame Deputy is the
speaker to the hospitals in cohort form
two of these schemes the west of it
hospital and the James Paget Hospital
Iraq hospitals and as I touched on a
moment ago uh uh have been confirmed as
part of the southern rock hospitals and
will therefore be funded for completion
by 2030.
remain on track for completion by 2030.
these are Milton Keynes Kettering
General Hospital Musgrove Park Hospital
in Taunton and tour Bay Hospital and
again I want to pay tribute to the
members for those constituencies
including their members for Milton
Keynes South and North the member for
Kettering the member for Taunton Dean
and the member at fortau Bay
the remaining seven hospitals within
this cohort Madame superco will also
proceed as part of the new hospitals
program the work will start on these
schemes over the next two years but they
will be part of a rolling program where
not all work will be completed by 2030
and this is a reflection of the
disruption that two years of the Kobe
pandemic has caused as well as the
pressure from construction inflation
some work within cohort 4 will start
next year and this includes a new
surgical Hub at Eastbourne alongside the
discharge Lounge already under
construction and we will discuss key
worker accommodation on the site with
the trust as part of Engagement with the
local Housing Association
Charing Crossing Hammersmith work will
begin on temporary Ward capacity to
enable the floor by floor refurbishment
to proceed in Nottingham work will begin
on a new surgical herb and three new
operating theaters will begin as part of
the wider redesign taking forward the
ockendon report recommendations
in Lancashire a new surgical Hub will be
opened at the Royal Preston Hospital
which is due to be completed this year
and we will reconfigure Services across
to trusts one of those sites uh Madam
Deputy speaker I'm sure will be of
interest to Mr Speaker as it is expected
to be near Chorley we are in active
discussion with the Royal Berkshire
given problems with the existing site
which had already made a 2030 completion
date very stretching in addition we are
building three new mental health
hospitals in surian borders Derbyshire
and musica and then turning to Devin
Madam Deputy speaker allowed me to pay
tribute to my right to my friend and
honorable friends and the member for
North Devon and the right honorable
member for torrage and West Devon uh who
have secured new community diagnostic
Centers at North Devon uh the discharge
Hub there is near completion and we will
take forward discussions with the trust
in terms of the local Housing
Association on key worker accommodation
over the next two years as the first
part of the north Devon new Hospital
built
uh and which we will also discuss the
original refurbished proposals alongside
uh the new build Hospital 2.0 option
so in summary Madame definite speaker
the cohort schemes will all proceed but
the commitment to completion by 2030
applies to the 40 schemes set out today
which meets our Manifesto commitment to
build 40 hospitals by 2013.
finally let me set out the merits or the
hospital 2.0 approach
building new hospitals this way has
clear advantages
construction experts estimate that with
modular design the efficiency saving
will be in the region of 25 percent per
square foot and this is essential to
addressing the pressures of construction
inflation and unlocking the additional
schemes that have been absorbed as a
result of the rap announcement
now there is one key risk Madam Deputy
speaker two today's announcement and
that is the plan announced by the party
opposite
as we speed things up they are
determined to grind them to a halt the
plan they set out on Monday said and I
quote
as a first step before we commit to any
more money we'd make an assessment of
all NHS capital projects to make sure
money is getting allocated efficiently
so the risk to these schemes is from the
benches opposite
Madame Deputy speaker
today's announcement confirms over 20
billion pounds of investment for the NHS
estate it confirms that all seven black
hospitals which NHS leaders have called
on the government to provide prioritize
will be prioritized we're complete
rebuilds using modern methods of
construction it allows all cohort 2
schemes to proceed once business cases
have been agreed a modular build will be
used for two of those schemes it gives
trust the certainty to begin enabling
works on major schemes in cohort 3 and a
package of early work for schemes in
cohort for two of which will be
accelerated as part of the rack program
Madam witch has been
speaking we committed to
till building Pro
inner generation and today we confirm
the funding to build 40 hospitals by
2030. I commend this statement to the
house
[Music]
Shadow secretary of state was streeting
thank you madam Deputy speaker
um and and can I well normally I'd thank
the Secretary of State for advanced
sight of his statement it did arrive
after we'd both arrived in the chamber
but it's all right we'll manage I just
thought though what an astonishing
coincidence that so many conservative
members that the Secretary of State name
checked happen to find their way in the
chain into the chamber at precise the
right moment it's like it's almost as if
they knew in advance but no I'll just
assume that they sped to the chamber
faster than the Home Secretary down the
motorway
um and of course
um you know I I think we can assume with
today's net migration figures that the
government have concluded that today is
a good day to bury bad news because
I wonder
I wonder Madame Deputy speaker as we go
through and I'll respond to the to the
statement
um in turn but I do wonder whether or
not at this stage in the life cycle of
13 years of conservative government the
public might have just begun to see
through uh the over-promising and under
delivering because the NHS estate is
crumbling after 13 years of their
neglect across England backlog
maintenance costs have more than doubled
from 4.4.7 billion in 2011-12 to 10.2
billion in 2021-2022
and we see the consequences of this
Leeds teaching Hospital saw over 100 raw
sewage leaks last year and let's not
beat about the bush Madden Deputy
speaker we're talking about urine and
feces leaking into Wards and patient
rooms Hampshire hospitals trust was
forced to suspend some Services because
of an uncontrollable rat infestation
and one of the health secretary's own
local hospitals in King's Lynn has
earned itself a special Accolade the
most propped Hospital in the country
over 4 000 steel and Timber support
props are supporting its dilapidated
roof enough to extend for six miles
leaking sewage rat infestations
collapsing roofs we are in this mess
because of conservative neglect and
mismanagement they literally didn't fix
the roof while the Sun was shining and
now patient safety is at risk indeed on
the rack hospitals in particular as the
Secretary of State said in this
statement I quote an independent
assessment shows they are not safe to
operate Beyond 2030. so indeed what a
relief to those communities that finally
the secretary of state has come forward
to confirm that they will at least be
built and I hope I hope that they will
do so at speed so that we can make sure
that this is at least one group of
hospitals that really is built by 2030.
because turning to his wider promise I
genuinely expected that the Secretary of
State might come to the house today and
be upfront about the fact that whatever
promise is the former prime minister the
member for Uxbridge and ruislip made in
2019 the pledge to build 40 new
hospitals by 2030 is simply not going to
happen because it was a straightforward
commitment 40 new hospitals except since
then we've become familiar with the idea
that they weren't new and astonishly
astonishingly they weren't even new
hospitals in fact since that General
section we've had more new health
secretaries than we've had new hospitals
and indeed we've got a case in point
like the new hospital some of them
aren't even new
uh in 2021 we discovered the August 21
we discovered the government's
definition of a new hospital when the
departmental memo on key media lines to
use when talking about the program
advised that fix-ups and paint jobs
should be included then in November of
that same year the government's own
infrastructure Watchdog called the
program and I quote unachievable
so what's changed in February of this
year it was revealed that only 10 of the
projects even had planning permission
and just last week the BBC reported that
building work is yet to start for 33 of
the 40 Projects promise in fact most are
still waiting to hear what their final
budget will be and none of the six that
were supposed to be ready for 2025 have
full planning permission or funding yet
and Madame Deputy speaker this matters
because people in these places were made
a promise and the secretary of state has
the audacity to repeat that promise
today when surely he knows that even if
the will is there and if even if as he
says the money is there
practically I simply do not see or
understand how he will be able to
deliver 40 new hospitals by 2030. so
will he now come clean and admit that
this is just another example of the
conservatives over promising and under
delivery because the fact is that thanks
to the dither and delay and the churn of
personnel from one Health secretary to
another indeed one prime minister to
another the program has been hit with
delays and uncertainty for years and as
a result the costs have soared and it is
less likely that they will ever be built
letting down taxpayers and letting down
patients and the Secretary of State also
now try to instill this sense of
Jeopardy that if there are a change of
government and there are a labor
government that somehow Hospital
buildings would become less likely now
he quoted the leader of the opposition
accurately but he didn't seem to under
understand the meaning it's quite right
to say that before we commit any more
money to capital projects we will want
to make sure that their fees that these
projects are feasible that they're good
value for money and will deliver the
Improvement that patients need but if
I've understood his statement correctly
the hospitals he's announced are all
fully funded now I can't wait to see the
detail of the fully funding but surely
if we're accepting him at face value and
these are fully funded well
there isn't going to be the need for any
more money from a labor government to
fund these 40 new hospitals so there's
no risk or Jeopardy at all assuming that
the money is there and the case stacked
up we did Madam Deputy speaker request
the National Audit office investigation
into the program and it's why we will
set up an office for value for money to
make sure we get value for every penny
of taxpayers money spent because the
conservatives have dithered so much that
it's been reported that the program is
now expected to cost twice as much as
original as originally estimated eye
watering 35 billion pounds
actually recognize that figure and if he
doesn't will he commit are publishing
the latest estimate his department has
made of the true cost of the program and
if indeed it's fully funded just explain
exactly where that money has come from
and Madam Deputy speaker this isn't just
about cost it's about the very real
threat to patient safety which is
irresponsible government is presiding
over day in day out in December their
health secretary acknowledged the
enormous concerns about reinforced
autoclaved area concrete used in certain
hospitals and the safety implications of
this he committed to eradicating it from
the NHS estate I do wonder why it has
taken six months to get to this point
and I wonder how many of the new
hospitals have now been kicked into the
long grass Beyond 2030 as a result of
the decisions that his department has
made today so in conclusion Madam Deputy
speaker isn't it time that the health
secretary came clean with a house and
came clean with the public and admitted
that the only place that these 40 new
hospitals by 23 exist is in the former
prime minister's imagination and in fact
what we have heard today is a plan on
paper but one that we'll never see
reality in practice
well it is a very strange
approaches just complain about members
coming to the chamber
and he almost sinks his own point with
his opening gambits because it is the
campaigning of members on this side of
the house who have campaigned for their
new hospitals and that is why when
colleagues see a statement on new
hospitals as part of their campaign it's
no surprise Madam Deputy speaker that
they would be in the whole in the
chamber to see that so so it's a pretty
odd situation to complain about members
coming to the chamber to be interested
in what is happening in their own
constituencies
um it's equally strange for the the
bench opposite to appear to be
complaining about a plan which they've
been calling for over recent weeks he
repeatedly formed the bench opposite
said he wanted to see the new hospitals
uh program plan we have set that out in
the statement today to which he says
he's concern that we've only got a plan
uh he equally
a clan on this side beats no plan on
that side
he he also seems to
um slightly oddly not welcome a
commitment to over 20 billion pounds of
investment in the NHS estate
and he further seems to have an
objection to me giving a commitment
Madame Deputy speaker to address the
issues of rack hospitals which NHS
leaders themselves have said should be
prioritized their independent reports
have said create a risk Beyond 2030 and
coming to a chamber after discussions
with Treasury and other colleagues
across government and confirming we now
have funding to address the seven rack
hospitals that he has called for action
on
um he then sort of seems to have an
objection in terms of uh speed and yet
the whole thrust on my statement was
about how we are changing our
methodology through the use of modern
methods of constriction learning from
what has been done in the education
sector in the the Justice sector in the
private sector in terms of delivering
construction schemes at PACE it gives
much more confidence in terms of cost it
stops local uh cheap assets changing
specs as disease designs are underway it
allows skins to be built much more
quickly it allows us to benefit from
technology we're Construction in
factories as opposed to being done in a
more conventional sense and that indeed
allows us to deliver schemes uh in a
much quicker Manner and it is for that
reason members on this side of the house
have campaigned so strongly for it
non-uh less so than the member for
Pendle my right humble friend who I know
has been a deciduous champion of the
case for Airedale and Champion that
scheme so the statement sets out we are
committed to addressing the VAC
hospitals by fixing that that has in
turn unblocked what was causing a delay
in terms of the program for the enabling
works for the cohorts uh three in
particular the cohort 2 where schemes
are very well Advanced will also now be
able to proceed and we also updated the
house on the the approach and the more
bespoke approach being taken in terms of
some of the cohort Falls and he is right
to talk
he's right to talk about sensor Jeopardy
because the point is the bench opposite
has said it wants to pause it wants to
review it wants to stop the schemes that
we will be proceeding with that is the
real risk to the new hospitals program
we have a new approach we have a clear
plan it is the party opposite that wants
to stop it
select committee Steve Bryan thank you
again I'm grateful for the statement the
select committee will want to have a
good look at it we'll start that when
the Secretary State comes to see us next
month now I promised my constituents
significant investment at Winchester
Hospital the last election that's
already happening and now early work and
cohort 4 we've got the promise of the
elective Hub to scale the orthopedic
list could the Secretary of State just
be clear though with my constituents
that as the New Hampshire hospital comes
together as part of the wider cohort
four it will be for clinicians to make
the clinical case as to what safe and
sustainable Services look like in the
long term for those people
it's interesting
there's different issues around
construction and service design in terms
of service design then obviously they'll
need to be discussions with local
clinicians and others
um as he knows with his scheme in terms
of North and mid uh Hampshire uh there's
issues around the the new site for the
junction 7 of the M3 uh where the
significant work around uh potential
land acquisition uh what upgrading on
the motorway would be required uh
there's a question in terms of the size
of that hospital versus other services
that are offered locally those are the
sort of issues that we're very keen to
get into discussion with the northern
mid Hampshire Trust on and that will be
all part of the Rolling program we take
forward
indeed Madam Deputy speaker on the Leeds
project I welcome the announcement of
the secretary of state has made but can
I press him on the detail
how much money
is going to be allocated to the Leeds
project
and will the standardized approach that
he has talked about have any flexibility
within it given the particular
characteristics of the lead site
uh which he knows and which is also
aware is cleared and ready to go
there's your state for reasons I'm sure
the house will recognize
um we for commercial confidential letter
reasons it would be unwise to say what
each scheme is allocated because that
would be most interesting to the
developers uh bidding for that work so
that is why wouldn't set out individual
allocations as he knows I've been to see
leads and I recognize uh the importance
of work there
um the modular design 2.0 and I pay
tribute to the work that Lord Markham
has done on this he brings real
commercial experience into the use of
modular methods of construction and
those schemes are designed to have some
Flex what we want to address uh having
sat for four years on the Public
Accounts committee is one of the
recurring themes during my time there
which was cost increasing because
specifications were changed mid-built
and one of the advantages of our modern
methods a construction approach is by
getting all the advice into the design
at the the front end we can standardize
design then have the benefits of scale
and maximize the national of the
National Health Service rather than
having individual schemes all of which
are at risk of specifications changing
and costs inflating
let's trust
thank you madam Deputy speaker I'd like
to thank my right honorable friend the
health secretary for listening to our
representations in West Norfolk and
announcing a new build for the Queen
Elizabeth in Kingsley as he knows the
hospital is in a poor State parts of it
are being held up by stilts the concrete
is crumbling and this announcement will
become as a huge relief to local
residents and will be extremely welcome
can my right humble friend confirm that
the new hospital will open its doors by
2030. well first can I pay tribute to my
right of a friend for her campaigning on
this issue together with the members
including mid Norfolk and North Norfolk
who have also led the campaign on this I
can confirm it will open by 2030 we
accept in full the findings of the
independent report that is why the rack
seven hospitals are being prioritized
and that is why today's announcement is
such great news for staff and patients
in Kingsland
Karen Bach Dr speaker
um so the Imperial anxious trust
including Saint Mary's Paddington has
the largest maintenance backlog in the
country we've had floods we've had fires
we've had sewage leaks we've had
collapsed ceilings
um I noticed that Saint Mary's Hospital
was not mentioned in the course of the
statement can the Secretary of State
confirm to me that Saint Mary's Hospital
will be completed as one of the 14
hospitals by 2030. sexual estate so
obviously since Mary's is part of uh
sort of three aspects of the Imperial
trust you've got the the work at
Hammersmith where we're building the
temporary Ward to unblock the
refurbishment which will be floor by
floor uh we've got the work at
Hammersmith with the cardiac we may want
such Hunter I'm literally trying to
explain the investment we're placing
into the constituencies so we've got
funding going into I've already told the
honorable I've asked him politely to
stop shouting now I hope he will do so
sexual estate thank you madam Deputy
speaker so we recognize uh the
importance of uh the Imperial trust bid
that's why we're starting to build the
temporary War capacity at Cheyenne cross
it's why the first phase of work is
underway on the cardiac elective
recovery Hub uh to bring cardiac work
onto the Hammersmith aside and in terms
of Saint Mary's we've already put some
initial funding in to explore a new site
with tfl and network rail as part of the
work and this will then go into the
rolling program of which Saint Mary's
will be part alongside the the redesign
that's needed taken on board the changes
that Charron cross and Hammersmith
Ian Duncan Smith
speaker I unreservedly welcome this
announcement a because my Hospital whips
Cross hospital for my constituents and
all the other residents I know secretly
in his heart the member of ilford North
also rejoices with me uh as uh as I want
to out him on this particular point he
stood on the line with me when we tried
to stop the last Labor government from
closing which Cross hospital so Together
We Will Rejoice over this I know he will
he's a decent chap so I simply say to my
radical friend 30 years I have
campaigned to have this Hospital rebuilt
to build it now will be a fantastic a
fantastic delivery to our constituents
he knows that I've badgered him I've
badged their Secretary of State down the
last 30 years and I batted his successes
actually that's also him as well while
we're at it so I simply say to him could
he please answer me this one simple
question will the work start physically
shovels in the ground work start on this
Hospital in the Autumn of this year
yes we expect enabling Works to start on
whips cross I know I've been as he knows
to the site with him we've seen the
urgency of it uh he has come hand as he
has said you know vigorously on this and
championed it uh throughout uh we're
very keen now we've unblocked the issue
around Iraq hospitals to get the
enabling works on the cohort 3 sites uh
started as soon as possible uh obviously
we will discuss with trusts now we've
got the clarity as to the precise
timetable uh but the funding for the
enabling Works to progress will now be
available and we'll work with the trust
to take that forward
Andy Slaughter thank you very much Madam
speaker in what way is delaying work on
Charing Cross and Hamilton's hospitals
speeding things up this is the most
shameful self-serving and nakedly
political statement I think I've ever
heard we've heard Imperial has one of
the big has the biggest backlog in the
country the Government tried for eight
years to demolish Charing Cross and now
they're promising a porter Cab in there
the only thing that gives me Comfort is
that the minister and the whole lot of
them will be out of here in a year's
time we can have a labor government that
can actually deliver for Imperial for
Charing clock for Hammer Smith of my
constituents
speaker he stood saying all the
hospitals locally are going to be closed
so it's good to have him good to have
him uh championing uh the the redesign
and refurbishment of those hospitals
that usually puts on these leaflets are
uh are going to be closed by a
conservative uh government uh what
really undermined his question was the
previous question from uh his colleague
because the whole point is we need to
look at the interaction between Charing
Cross Hammersmith and Saint Mary's
collectively the design of services
needs to be looked across the Imperial
trust as as a collective there's
questions around a potential new sites
where tfl and network rail uh vis-by
Saint Mary's and in terms of Charing
Cross we need to create some temporary
Ward capacity in order then to unblock
the refurbishments which we will do
floor by Florida is a very tightly
constrained site and it does need a
bespoke approach and that's what Madame
Deputy speaker we're we're sitting out
here where schemes can follow a
standardized design we will have a
modular 2.0 approach but there are some
schemes that need a refurbishment that
have particular site issues and we will
work through those on a more bespoke way
David Morris Deputy speaker this is
marvelous news across the country but I
would like to ask the Secretary of State
um the the decision on Lancaster
um I believe that I've heard that we may
be getting a new hospital it may be
further on down the line however we are
in need of one and I know that any news
he could give us would be not just um
fantastic news to myself after all the
lobbying I've done to to my honorable
friend and his predecessors much like
The Honorable right honorable friend
from chingford but it will be also
welcome news by my honorable friend in
this context The Honorable lady from
Lancaster the MP of Lancaster
he's right it's not just the Eden
project on which my uh honorable friend
has been a vigorous uh campaigner and he
has assiduously raised uh this as well
as he knows the trust is at a very early
stage uh in terms of considering for
example what public consultation will be
needed around the reconfiguration of
services across Lancaster We're not
letting that stop us in terms of work
for example that opening a new surgical
Hub at the Royal Preston as he knows I
know the geography very well in terms of
the interaction uh with Lancaster
there's a number of options around
consolidation and expanding Services
onto two sites and I look forward to
having discussions with him as we take
that forward
Daisy Cooper thank you madam Deputy
speaker
um having asked the government to
release funding to West Hearts Hospital
trust and other Hospital trusts 14 times
I'm relieved that they've now got
approval to proceed but the secretary of
state will know as the rest of us do
that the construction industry think the
2030 date is Pie in the Sky because the
government hasn't been looking after our
hospitals we've lost huge parts of the
workforce and our supply chains building
magazine says that the contract notice
for delivery partner won't even be uh
published until September and of course
none of the major construction companies
as I understand it have even started
have even started to put together
project teams to bid for the work so for
all this talk of 2030 could the
Secretary of State tell us how much
progress he's prepared to promise before
the next general election
States well as I say firstly the
announcement and the manifesto
commitment was around our commitment to
build by 2030 but she touches on uh the
engagement with industry Lord Markham
has been engaging with industry we've
had a significant team both within the
department with and in NHS England
working on uh the standardized designs
the whole point is we have seen in other
sectors how having standardization
allows us to construct much more quickly
and it also will allow internal
processes within government to be much
quicker because we're not looking at
each scheme in a bespoke way we will
have much more standardization so that
is how we will move at much quicker Pace
it has required us to take a little more
time over recent months as we finalized
this plan but now we have that and we
have the clarity particularly around the
VAC hospitals we will be able to move
with much more pace
warmly my right honorable friends
statement and confirmation that the New
Hampshire hospital trust Hospital in
Basingstoke is one of his cohort four
hospitals due for completion in
2032-33 and will serve residents both in
my constituency and also in a number of
other honorable and right honorable
members as well we have a plan
we have a preferred site we have an
amazing team on the ground so how can my
right honorable friend work with me and
other colleagues to speed up this new
hospital it's badly needed to replace
the current Hospital which was built in
the 1970s to last last 50 years we have
one of the biggest backlogs of
Maintenance we need that new hospital to
really meet the needs of our growing
populations we have some of the highest
levels of house building in the
Southeast what can he do to help
my friend has campaigned deciduously on
this I know how passionately she has led
the campaign I stand ready to have
further discussions with Hershey's right
on the uh the trust going into the
rolling program and that's how it will
be taken forward as I touched on with
the chair of the health slip committee
there are some questions which we're
keen to work through not least around
Junction 7 the land acquisition and some
of the service design and I know she
will be at the fore in terms of making
representations on those points
I like
uh the Secretary of State to clarify the
position on North Manchester General
Hospital it's not in the written
statement I didn't hear mention it when
but when the right honorable member for
Oxbridge in South ruislip announced the
original building scheme North
Manchester General Hospital was in the
top six if not the top hospital because
its problems are not mid-20th Century
Concrete they're in the mid 19th century
buildings which need replacing with
modern buildings I'd like to thank the
Secretary of State for emailing me in
the Middle East speech I think that was
very clever
I got the email when he was on his feet
um where he says initial works and
progress can start I'd like to tell him
that that has happened grounds are being
cleared uh a car park is under
construction a new mental health unit is
being built on that site
but the final clearance for what was a
half billion pound scheme has has not
been given and when I've been in
correspondence with the the trust
they've said they can't get it will the
Secretary of State give that clearance
for the final go-ahead now and Willie
return to North Manchester and visit the
hospital I know he's been before
sexual mistakes I I have been before as
he knows not least because I was a
unsuccessful candidate in 1997 when The
Honorable Jones was elected to uh the
house uh first time uh very happy to
ensure that a note comes with any
further clarification as I will take
that away and pick that up with the the
department uh I know enabling Works did
commence in 2022 uh there's been
extensive demolition works that has been
uh continuing into 2023 uh there is as
he's well aware the key dependency for
the park House mental health project
which needs to uh also be factored in uh
the multi-story car park is in
construction so that work is already
underway but I hope what it can see from
the statement today is the clarity that
it will bring in terms of the
conversations we can now have with trust
in terms of the enabling works and the
next steps but I'm very happy to get a
more detailed note to him following the
statement
I know first thank you Deputy speaker I
know my right honorable friend in
particular for Harlow yourself Madam
Deputy speaker as member for Epping and
the member for Hartford and stortford
have all led a showcase turbocharged
campaign for a new princess Alexandra
Hospital for Harlow in Essex any
services in Essex benefits the whole of
Essex but can I also thank the Secretary
of State for the 8 million pounds
invested into South End hospital for a
new reconfigured a e plans are
progressing very well doesn't this
multi-million pound investment show that
we have a government here committed to
improving health care for everyone
across our brilliant County
secretaries well I very much agree with
my honorable friend and she's right to
draw attention to the 8 million
investment in south end and also the
wider Capital program Madame Deputy
speaker not least the rollout of
diagnostic Centers and the role at a new
surgical herbs which are all part of his
tackling the pandemic backlogs and is
part of our commitment to investing in
the NHS estate
Ian Stewart thank you madam Deputy
speaker with your Indulgence at first
just place on record my deep sadness at
the passing of Karen Lumley today she
was a very dear friend as well as a
valued colleague and she was very much
missed uh may I thank my right honorable
friend for the announcement that I'm
confirmation of the funding for the new
women and maternity unit at Milton
Keynes Hospital uh can you give me an
assurance that he will work with Joe
Harrison the excellent chief executive
and his team to bring forward as many
enabling works as as is possible because
the site is ready to be developed almost
immediately
Assurance in fact uh I have uh very
frequent meetings with the chief
executive Milton keys not least because
he provides National leadership in our
development on the NHS app I know he
Champions the Milton Keynes uh site and
its next steps and I'm very keen to
continue to work constructively with him
Dean Russell
Deputy speaker I'm really Overjoyed
about this statement today I was
grateful that my right honorable friend
took up my end of his invitation earlier
this year to visit Watford General
Hospital and my hope at that time was to
make the argument in person at the
hospital why this was so important that
we had the new build and he listened and
this announcement is beyond my
expectations I did the words fully
funded mean so much to my constituents
across Watford and West Hart and it
means a state-of-the-art fully funded
world-class Hospital in my view and it's
a result of years of tireless
campaigning both by myself and my
predecessor and I may say that the
member for Emma Hempstead has also said
that he's supportive which I think is
fantastic news so along with accepting
my heartfelt Lance and for listening to
all my pleas and my arguments and my
pitching and my probably annoying
conversations about this uh would my
right humble friend join me in thanking
the leadership team at West Hearts
Hospital trust for all their hard work
and planning to make this a possibility
today and would you also agree with me
that the new hospital will not only
transform health care for the entire
area of Watford and West Hart but also
create a Cutting Edge 21st century
workplace for our fantastic staff and
volunteers across the area thank you
well uh Mr Deputy speaker my ongoing
friend is not only championed uh Watford
hospital I know he has worked there as a
volunteer on many uh occasions uh and he
uh has been compelling in the
representations he made to uh ministers
across government on the case for
investment in Watford it's a huge
tribute to him and as he says it's also
a tribute to the wider leadership team
in Watford he's right that it will have
a transformative effect and I have seen
firsthand with him uh the Urgent case
for investment in Watford that he has
championed
the commitment to Milton Keynes Hospital
which is a key hospital that serves my
constituents alongside Stoke Mandeville
which also enjoys a new pediatric a e
the Jr and Wickham and it's the case of
Wickham Mr Deputy speaker that shows it
is not just reinforced autoclaved
aerated concrete that trusts our
grappling with the tower at Wickham
needs at least 80 million pounds in
maintenance and repairs or preferably as
the trust plans a full decant with a 200
million pound purpose-built plan Care
Center that will take National spending
so what hope can my right humble friend
offer buckinghamshire patients that
Wickham's plans couldn't become a
reality
well as we touched on a moment ago Mr W
speaker there are a range of initiatives
that we are doing across the NHS estate
in terms of Wickham specifically the the
leadership team from the get it right
first time so Professor Tim breaks for
example recently visited Wickham to
discuss uh proposals with the senior
clinical team and of course we look
forward to working constructively with
the local ICS as they design the right
fit for Wickham and the wider system
state for his personal interest in and
commitment to Kettering General Hospital
and his visit to the hospital last July
will my right humble friend confirm that
Kettering General Hospital's place in
the National new hospitals program
continues to be secured with a fully
funded redeveloped improved and expanded
Hospital due on the existing site by
2030 in line with the original timeline
speaker in my statement the the place of
Kettering in the new hospitals program
is secure and that is in large part of a
result of the campaigning of my
honorable friend the member for
Kettering who has raised this issue on a
very regular basis with me also show me
first-hand the issues of Kettering I
know he has championed investment in
Kettering Hospital and today's
announcement is a very positive day for
staff and patients of Kettering universe
on behalf of my Constitution
particularly in middlewich and sandbach
can I warmly welcome the excellent news
to rebuild Layton hospital and thank
ministers for responding to the
determined local campaigning on this
commendably led by my honorable friend
the member for crew now which and also
involving the members for edisbury and
Macclesfield and without wanting to
detract from this however could I I also
again Ask the minister to look at
congleton War Memorial Hospital could I
I ask that the secretary of state would
meet with me to consider how the
services and Facilities there can be
expanded and modernized as there is
capacity for the site to serve the local
residents of congleton and demand of
course is increasing as house building
has increased in the area so well I know
the the my honorable friend the member
for congleton has championed this
investment in her health system and
she's right that this serves a number of
constituencies and it's part of a wider
system transformation as I touched on
with other Investments such as in a
diagnostic Centers and their surgical
herbs in terms of new housing that is a
specific issue that my honorable friend
who leads on primary care has been
looking at in particular in terms of how
we get the the right level of
contribution from new housing going in
to health facilities locally and I know
he'll be very happy to discuss that with
her moving forward James Wilde
it's fantastic news that the Queen
Elizabeth hostel is now one of the new
hospitals this government is committed
to building and I'm delighted that the
case I've been making with very strong
local support has been accepted so on
behalf of my Northwest Norfolk
constituents and everyone at team qh can
offer huge thanks to my reliable friend
the health secretary for the
determination he's shown to resolving
the rack safety issues and will he
confirmed this is a fully funded plan so
there will be a fit for the future
Hospital in King's Lynn by 2030. well I
pay tribute Mr Deputy speaker for the
work that my unreal friend has done to
Champion the case for Kings Lynn he has
raised this issue with me and the
ministerial team on a very regular basis
uh he has been compelling on that issue
and I'm very happy to confirm as set out
in the statement that this will enable
Kingsland to be rebuilt and that is
fully funded
for virus sorry thank you Mr Deputy
speaker I welcome today's statement and
I've been working with the Royal Barks
On the building better Berkshire
Community engagement program and there
is a palpable enthusiasm within my own
constituency that we're going to have a
new state-of-the-art hospital on our
doorstep but as my writing well friend
said in his statement we're in cohort
for and there are issues with the
specific site so could I ask him for a
guarantee that there will be a rebuild
at the Royal box and also could he set
out the next step so that I can reassure
my constituents as to what what lies
ahead I'm going to say a honorable
friend is right on both counts first
that uh the robot chair is part of the
Rolling new hospital program but
secondly there are complexities with
that site as she knows firstly part of
the site is grade one listed and
secondly there's been some specific
issues in terms of the existing site on
which survey work has been undertaken so
that is having an impact uh in terms of
the the target date for work we are
funding a mental health crisis facility
this year along with the the survey work
and I very much look forward to having
further discussions with her as about
progressives
if you're a Mayhew this could not be
better news for the people of broadland
on the west of my constituency they're
going to be served by a brand new field
at the Queen Elizabeth Hospital at
King's Lynn and on the other end of my
constituency the James Paget a brand new
hospital serving constituents there
joining the work of the Norfolk and
Norwich University Hospital in the
center can my rightful friend just
confirm that the modular nature of the
design will still provide the absolute
first class facilities that the people
of Norfolk deserve
so firstly Mr Deputy speaker today's
announcement is transformative for
healthcare in Norfolk for the reasons my
honorable friend sets out uh their new
hospital that James Paget and a new
hospital at King's Lynn and of course
there are further away from government
in terms of diagnostic Centers and
surgical hubs on which there will be
further discussion in terms of the
quality of the modular design we are
bringing the country's leading experts
together as well as engaging with the
market to finalize those designs so that
we can have the best input as we
standardize the design and then roll
that out as the template for schemes at
King's Lynn and James pageant so the
quality of the scheme should be of a
very high order
Robbie Moore thank you Mr Deputy speaker
after three and a half years of tireless
campaigning of constant lobbying to the
government raising the high structural
risk profile of Airedale Hospital due to
its aerated Concrete Construction I'm
delighted to hear of today's
announcement from the dispatch box that
we're going to be getting a new Airedale
Hospital which is going to be fit for
the future can I put on record my thanks
to the Airedale NHS Foundation trust for
their hard work including my neighboring
members in this place as well as the
Prime Minister Chancellor and the health
secretary for listening and take on
board our concerns can my right
honorable friend come and visit the
great team at Airedale hospital and will
he give reassurance to me that this
Hospital our new Airedale hospital will
be built and open by 2030.
well I I know my honorable friend has
campaigned assiduously over the last
three years uh to make a compelling case
for Ayo Dale I very much look forward to
the opportunity to visit uh in uh due
course and the commitment in the
statement today is to ensure that that
is built to the 2030 time scale
thank you uh given Secretary of State's
answer to my honorable friend from
Winchester and my Rachel for a friend
for for Basingstoke I wonder if I could
just press him a little further for some
clarity on the replacement for
Basingstoke Hospital notwithstanding the
complexities that he outlined in his
previous answers on the site could he
just confirm it is agreed that a
replacement is needed for the hospital
that the money is in the budget to do so
and that notwithstanding the
complexities of the site that a site
will be found and a new hospital will be
open in the early 2030s to serve all of
our constituents
so uh on the uh the the issues he raised
so as firstly it is agreed that a
replacement is needed and that the north
of mid Hampshire will go into the
rolling program for the new hospital uh
program uh and that aside as a result
will be failed and the intention is to
work to us at 20 32 33 uh time scale so
that is uh the plan
um already the the original time scale
will stretch because of some of the
complexity uh that is involved and of
course I also signal just how long uh
previous designs and hospitals have
taken so we're speeding up the
construction side but we also need to
address some of the issues particularly
around 2007 and the site design
caramela
yeah speaker can I very warmly welcome
this announcement and pay tribute to the
leadership of Leighton Hospital who have
relentlessly advocated for this this has
been a three-year team effort campaign
particularly with the member for
edisbury also the member for congleton
and others and I want to thank the
thousands of residents who signed the
petition backing this campaign and I
know the team will be itching to get
started could you outline perhaps what
the next steps will be for later in the
other sites
well again personally can I pay tribute
both to his campaigning work but also
the work that he did as a volunteer
during lockdown in his local hospital
which I know was extremely well received
and he's right he has campaigned along
with uh my honorable friends the member
for edisbury and congleton uh to make
the case for this investment I'm very
happy to have further discussions with
him as as the the liaison with the Trust
on the next steps moves forward they
never
thank you Mr Deputy speaker um I'm sure
the uh the health secretary is is
absolutely sick of the the sight of me
of uh campaigning from Milton Keynes new
women and children's hospital
um both in his current role and in his
previous role at the treasury in the
event that he isn't sick of the size of
me would he would he like to come up to
Milton Keynes look at the site
um look at where we can keep our foot on
the pedal get some enabling Works going
we're going to hit that 2030 Target but
there's no reason why we can't get
cracking and get started straight away
yeah
you say it's always a pleasure Mr Deputy
speaker to see my own real friend uh
what whatever the issue but he is right
that he uh has assiduously raised uh the
case for Milton Keynes uh as as he's uh
his neighbor the member uh for Milton
Keynes South and they worked very
effectively as a team to make uh the
case uh I look forward to having further
discussions with him as we take the
plans forward Mr Fletcher
speaker he was first will be last and he
was last will one day be first
I thank the Secretary of State for his
statement and I congratulate all members
who have been successful with their
business for a new hospital sadly there
is not
um well there's one they're missing on
here Mr Smith Mr Deputy speaker and that
is Doncaster and although I understand
the need for the Iraq Hospital
Replacements and it is desperately
needed and although and also know that
many of my constituents will be
benefiting from the new a e Department
uh in in Basset law it does not remove
the need for Doncaster to have a new
hospital there is a Brownfield site
right in the center of Doncaster that is
shovel ready and ready to go so will the
secretary of state meet with me maybe
the chancellor and maybe the Secretary
of State for the Department of leveling
up to see what we can do to get
Doncaster a new hospital because it's
not just a new hospital it would
actually Revitalize the city of
Doncaster and we really really need this
thank you appreciate it well my
honorable friend is right to Champion
the case of Doncaster as he knows whilst
it's not in his constituency the
investment that will make in ambassad
law is for patient care that uh in a
number of instances will directly serve
his own constituents uh in Doncaster
that's why it's right we look at capital
investment on a system-wide basis and
I'm very happy to have further
discussions with him uh in conjunction
with his local ICS integrated care
system as to their future plans in terms
of their capital investment